go through checkout tap your card
and there you paid in less than two
seconds it's faster than hold on
this and safer than this that quick
exchange is thanks in large part to
these just a few little wires that make
contactless payments possible
here's a look inside the tech that makes
those payments both quick and secure
and why tap to pay has taken so long to
gain Traction in the US this is the tech
behind tap to pay
at the heart of tab to pay is a
technology called NFC or near field
communication which itself is a specific
form of RFID or radio frequency
identification you might be familiar
with it as a way to unlock your hotel
room for example NFC relies on those
little wires which are actually antennas
the antenna kind of looks like a race
track and it's sort of a coil of
different wires and that's what's used
to basically transmit the radio
frequency on both sides this is Mike
McLennan he's the general manager of
hardware at Square a company that makes
card readers and he cracked one open to
show us exactly how adaptive paid
transaction Works reminds me a lot of
opening oysters
card readers also have those antennas
this is the NFC antenna so this is the
magic of what makes NFC transactions
work and you can see once we pull it off
how thin the NFC antenna is
the card and the reader are what he
calls passive and active connections the
reader is active because it has power
and can initiate radio communication on
its own and the card is passive because
it doesn't have power and needs to be
near an active source to initiate that
communication tapping your phone works
the same way because your phone emulates
the passive card what's happening right
now is the coil in here is active and
it's looking for a card basically
anywhere within this sort of region up
here it's doing that using a radio
frequency specific to NFC devices which
only works at a very short range a
maximum of about four centimeters and
when the reader finds the card it
requests the information needed for
payment that information is stored here
in your cards chip one thing it stores
is what's known as static data meaning
information that's the same every time
you use your card that's things like the
account number and expiration date it's
what's sent from your card's magnetic
stripe when you swipe but your chip
doesn't just send that static data when
you tap it also sends something called a
cryptogram a unique string of numbers
the issuers used to verify that your
card is valid what the card is doing is
it's collecting information from the
reader about the transaction about the
reader specifically and it's combining
that with the card information
using its cryptographic key to create a
unique number for that transaction
that's what makes it really hard to
replicate a card fraudulently is because
the card needs to have a cryptographic
key that lets them generate that like
secret code
that information is fed through this the
payment board which sorts to the data
that needs from the card and puts it all
into an encrypted package
that package then gets sent off to the
main board which then sends that on to
the our servers which then send it on to
the networks like Visa Mastercard MX
which then send it on to the issuer and
then back with the approval message once
you get to this board it's all encrypted
and protected information and so
anything beyond uh this will have a high
degree of security involved in it all of
that happens in just a few seconds
faster than inserting your chip so when
you insert a chip card into a reader
there's a few back and forth in that
communication whereas in contact list
there's just fewer back and forth it was
just built as a more efficient more
streamlined only the bare necessities
kind of information being passed back
and forth card networks and Security
Experts say that this is also more
secure than other ways you can use your
card unlike swiping your static data is
better protected during that
communication and because it doesn't
have contact with the reader it's not
susceptible to malware that can affect
ship insert transactions on rare
occasions
this tap to pay technology has taken off
in the last few years in part because of
the push for contactless during the
pandemic Square says such payments
tripled between the beginning of 2020
and the end of 2022 while other
countries like the UK have had
contactless integrated into public
transportation for years it's taken the
U.S more than a decade to get here for a
whole new way to pay MasterCard
introduces pay pass U.S first started
issuing tap to pay cards in the 2000s
Peter rudiger is a Wall Street Journal
reporter who covers payments and
financial technology different banks
thought it was a cool new technology and
thought their consumers would really
flock to it didn't really work out just
because there were a few businesses that
were set up to accept tap to pay U.S
retailers have been slow to replace
Payment Systems in part because they're
expensive to change in 2022 about 55
percent of merchants said they accepted
tap to pay with others saying they were
planning on implementing it consumer
behaviors are also difficult to change
and the switch to contact lists didn't
feel urgent it's just often been
described as a solution in search of a
problem yes it might be convenient and
yes it might be safe but that's not
usually enough for people to switch
their behavior
the tech still has room to grow and the
push to integrate it into more parts of
everyday life is working in its favor in
New York for example Subway Riders can
now tap to pay at turnstiles so you have
this big push to get to have to pay into
more transportation systems and get
people used to using it you know every
day and if you're going to use tap to
pay to get on and off the subway at
least twice a day maybe you'll also use
it for your coffee your lunch your
drinks at least that's the idea that the
credit card companies hope happens
square and other companies have also
recently released to the functionality
to use the NFC antenna in your phone as
the active connection essentially
putting a reader in your pocket which
could make it easier for small retailers
to accept card payments this is showing
you where it wants you to tap and so the
NFC antenna on your phone is right
behind this and so when I take my NFC
enabled credit card and I hold it over
there
done
transaction complete